hi there I'm Stephanie Owens
professional lettering artist and
educational director here at the future
and you are watching a portfolio review
that I took part of with creative
director Greg Gunn to help our future
community members land their dream
clients and if you'd like some future
eyeballs on your portfolio then head on
over to our accelerator program where
we'll look at your portfolio your
capabilities deck your website and
you'll get weekly coaching calls with me
and Mr Ben Burns and now the portfolio
review
okay okay so
Jerry the most mag creative director
illustration design video
okay I like that like there's a nice
little image there it's clear who he is
what he does how to contact him most
importantly that's great and then view
portfolio Okay cool I'm in
let's go
okay so I think the the first thing that
uh I remember noticing Stephanie as we
scroll
is that there are
so many projects here I think there was
36 projects total yeah which is fine
but maybe not all at once yeah it's
impressive
um but overwhelming for sure and um
and I mean again I I think they're the
thumbnails need need work because I know
for a fact that the work is better than
what is being shown in the thumbnails so
that would be my my other observation
um but showing show me that many
projects also makes me think like
there's no way they can all be the best
right like in my mind your portfolio
should be your your best at any given
time right and it changes over time and
it changes with who you want to talk to
as well yeah so I think that was a
question we had for Jerry and well even
though you're not here Jerry if you're
watching the replay like who is this for
think about who you really want to reach
with this and cater that just like we
said to Miguel cater this this portfolio
to them and if you have multiple people
that you want to reach with this maybe
categorize the work and have you know
category one is maybe your creative
direction for film and you can have your
three breast projects and then maybe
another one is
um video and then have your three best
projects and then you can link to the
other video projects because I feel like
the chances of someone coming to this
it's a bit overwhelming in terms of the
amount of things but they also aren't
looking for you to do a logo and a video
it's I mean maybe but most people have
an idea in mind of what they are needing
and so if they need
if they need these thumbnails these um
icons I want to very easily be able to
find these icons
I think to
to yes and what uh Stephanie mentioned
it's like if
it's hard to know who it's for so if
it's for potential clients I think that
would
completely change how we'd suggest you
know presenting this work but if it's
for like an agency or a studio or uh
yeah like an in-house kind of position
then I I think the all the Improvement
stuff talked about are are valid and
it's it's really a problem of like
edit right editing down your your
absolute best and as a creative director
I I know it's it's hard to sort of like
have a particular like
style or Focus which I think is okay so
showing showing a breadth of work is
great
um but your your choice of thumbnail
will really help sort of make or break
um how that how that project's being
perceived and you know it's it's
relevancy to like who's looking at it
right so
we also talked about for things like
this where is maybe not clear what your
role was you know the career have a bit
of additional context text here like did
you do video for this or was it creative
direction or for the for a film creative
direction or or whatever it was
specifically that you did like right
here you put wow Bakery promotional
video so just giving it a little bit
more context of exactly what you did for
the project yeah even like client who
the client was in your role that's like
a really kind of simple way to do it
um
yeah
and then we also talked about like for
this one we don't have any kind of so
this is like the opposite problem of
Miguel there's there's no context and
these are super cool yeah these are all
like like could I see this on like in
use could I could I get a creative brief
at the top you do say who the client was
if the project is still active on USA
today could you link to the project was
there an art director involved give
credit to the art director
um and I would love to see all of these
in a pattern all the way like in a
banner all the way across
um to kind of see how they work as a set
and I think the Barbie one as well you
have a Barbie project where there's not
a lot of context given as to what your
role was the work is super cool
yeah yeah this is great like I like we
have the the client what was your role
what was this what was the scope of the
project too I know like as a career
director sometimes you have to sort of
talk about something in abstract that
happens to be very big
um or has a lot of steps So You Know
Your Role scope of the work and and yeah
just like a couple sentences about the
the objective what was the problem and
how did you solve it I think if you can
provide that information you're you're
good that's a very good place to start
um was there anything else other than
digging into
I think it was this one that we were
looking at maybe it wasn't this one oh
no no I know which one it was we were
looking at and we wanted to give some
it was the Rangers rangers yeah art
Direction okay of course
okay so I've got the video cool
yeah I think what we loved about this
was like
there's
a sort of
fantastic collection of like the work
that was ultimately produced and then a
lot of process stuff which is is always
really cool and kind of fun to look look
through but again we're sort of
missing the context
um and missing what your role was in in
all this and how you contributed and
added value to this
um again what was a problem uh what was
the solution and how did you get there
uh yeah cause this is all really great
really great stuff
I think also Miguel I would say the same
for you like when you're
creating images for a case study or
something like this like try to format
all of them consistently you know like
so if they're all big and wider 16x9
sort of leave it leave it as that
um it just kind of helps the the flow of
things so when things get sort of like
wide and smaller and like it's it's a
little kind of funky so hey yeah and if
something's really tall like this like
this poster is really awesome
it might be better served in a mock-up
versus like having a really tall thing
to scroll through because we we can't
really see it in its entirety because of
how how tall it is and short the screen
is like this could be in a a movie
theater mock-up of like coming soon
movies or something like that so we can
see the whole experience
um and I think this also might be a
template limitation of being on my
portfolio.com so we're also going to
recommend Jerry that you um you get your
own domains set up in simple Squarespace
site
um
Squarespace or anything no no not
neither of us even use it it's just I
have used it in the past and I do know
that it's extremely easy to use and it
looks very professional I know you also
while I'm talking about images and
Squarespace and all moving um you you
said in your survey that one of the
things you wanted to focus on was
improving your web your web presence and
while we're not going to get into all of
that I do want to talk about
um SEO for a second so when you are on a
a platform like this Greg filled me in
that it's going to change is that
correct it's going to change the file
name to a number for you automatically
Greg yeah Jerry we're assuming you
didn't label your file this so I'm
guessing it probably Auto changed it
when you uploaded it
um but yeah if you can name it what it
is like
Jerry Jerry muscle Mack I'm sorry if I
mispronounce your name creative director
project name
you know it's just like more SEO kind of
yeah stuff that always helps and that's
going to help with your web presence I
know we we have gotten work from being
found on a Google search so it's it's
never bad to think about those things
and since we want you to move platforms
anyway it's just another bonus of why
you should be moving platforms your
website will look your work will look
more presentable to a client and you'll
also get that as I like to call it
Google glitter spread the Google glitter
all over the website
um did you want to show a project that
you thought could be good inspiration
for how to
show a creative Direction like this
yeah yeah so uh Jerry we we found this
website it's uh from another creative
director
and I've seen this before and I saw all
the swords and stuff and I was like oh
man I've seen a case study that was
really great that was similar look to
this and so we tracked it down and so I
think this is a really nice uh sort of
parallel to maybe what you could do
um so you can clearly see like client
Warner Brothers games a brief
description of what it is and then it
sort of just gets in gets into the work
um
and as we kind of scroll through you
know there's like
little bits of context that's provided
and like I said as a creative director
you know it's kind of like a the scope
can oftentimes be very big and so it's
all about kind of telling a story right
as you go as you go through and I think
um uh in this case this creative
director does a really great job of
doing that of you know sharing the the
process and the sort of story of how
this project was conceived the problems
they run into and ultimately what the
outcome was
um
yeah I thought this was really great
this is like a cool a cool mock-up it's
actually like a maybe I don't know if
it's a video or a gif or something but
it's
like just the fact that it moves makes
it more interesting too and since this
is a more video based project I think
that that makes sense
um short and sweet sentences I mean look
at even this is three sentences but it's
still super concise and small like don't
write three rambling sentences
two lines if you can give me two lines
and I'm more likely to read it
um
yeah and then they also included uh this
whole behind the scenes section
um and you can see they cropped
everything so it's the same sort of
frame size so as you scroll down it kind
of feels like it all it all belongs
together too which I think is cool
um
and going back to what you said about a
neutral background like it's not white
but it works and it will work with every
project there will be no Clashing of the
what is this creamy yeah
distract I think that's the goal right
yeah you wanted to sort of just Fade
Into the background a bit
and I want to say yeah he had some
credits at the bottom too yes he does
okay so his links to press which is
awesome and then agency credits which
this is a massive project go on forever
I put credits on all my work this is
like next level
um
you don't have to go this nuts but I
think like especially if you're a
creative director
um a part of your job is you know like
propping up your team and uh that also
helps with you know selling yourself as
a a leader
um is you know who your team was made of
like and how you all work together and
sort of foster that collaborative nature
so I think the work is great uh there's
an edit process that needs to happen and
I I think a little bit of context for
how you you know to to go with how
you're presenting the work
um
uh working on the thumbnails a little
bit
and yeah some of the other kind of
presentation
uh suggestions we had from Miguel about
like you know how to present your work
in a mock-up or you know just kind of
like frame it in in a more pleasing way
um I would also for this one in
particular Greg because he's looking for
clients I would put some sort of call to
action at the bottom of it that's like
you know was he looking for clients is
that I think he was looking for clients
I believe oh okay I don't think he
specified actually
so if you're looking for clients you
know I would definitely put a CTA button
and we did recommend that you have a
contact page even though you do put it
on your home page and you do put your
contact information on your about page
people uh forget and they want to easily
be able to like if I'm here and I'm like
okay well how do I get a hold of you and
I don't see a contact button it's just
easy just put a little contact button
with your details yeah make it easy yeah
super easy
foreign